I think architects are more necessary
than ever um because technology can
sometimes create the illusion that a
building can be created without a
creative hand without a creative idea
behind it and that's not true at all
where technology has helped so far is in
the building of extraordinary shapes
that architects can imagine so you know
was once possible to imagine strange and
complicated shapes that were almost
impossible to build today technology
allows us to build almost anything but
the computer can't create those things
it can't make them up an architect has
to make them up and in fact if we think
about Frank Gehry again he is in many
ways a very traditional architect I mean
he designs on paper and with models and
then the computer takes over only later
now there's a younger generation of
architects who are using the computer
more as a design tool up and they're
comfortable with letting the computer
tell them kind of what to do a little
bit more rather than merely how to make
something that their mind has invented I
don't know where that's going to take us
I'm I don't I don't think if i sell was
old but i think i'm old enough to not
sort of naturally feel that that's the
way to do it but i'm also i hope smart
enough not to rush to judgment on it so
let's see we're using the computer as an
actual design tool as opposed to an
engineering and construction tool or as
a facilitation tool where all that takes
us i don't know yet but i do believe
that in the same way that computers can
be programmed to write music to paint
pictures to write literature I don't
know that there will be a time when they
will equal the creative genius
of a human mind but they certainly can
facilitate that genius and that we're
seeing already I think we can get tired
of crazy shapes all the time and we get
numb to them you know and if every as
robert venturi and denise scott brown
wrote many many years ago you know if
every building is extraordinary well
then they're really all ordinary you
know so that if the new ordinary just
becomes a kind of frantic frenetic
complicated form i don't know that we've
achieved much the the beauty and the
drama in any kind of urban environment
of any kind of urban setting is in the
way in which different things play off
against each other I mean if you had a
building like Frank Gehry's Walt Disney
Hall in Los Angeles next door to another
Gehry building next door to another all
of the same thing I don't or equally
powerful buildings by other architects I
don't know that you'd have a
particularly appealing urban environment
but in the same way that you know a
great Cathedral in a European city plays
off against the everyday buildings that
are there and becomes a kind of
punctuation mark if you will in the
cityscape that's what we should be doing
is technology going to create a
temptation to do too much all the time
it may but if I said I think our growing
awareness of urbanism of the idea of the
city which i think is better understood
culturally today than it was 20 years
ago I think that that sort of helps
balance that off and we're much more
aware that the background building in
fact can be one of the things that makes
a city really nice to be it I mean think
about Paris you know they're they're
great monuments but then is the kind of
the ordinary everyday Parisian building
that creates the urban fabric and that's
one of the reasons it works so well is
because the great monuments playoff in a
really beautiful sort of harmonic
balance
against the the background fabric